we're continuing our tour through
truly incompetent new trumpy members of
the house
and congresswoman lauren beaubert
is at the top of the list along with
marjorie taylor greene
and madison cawthorne and as you may or
may not know
lauren beaubert demands to be armed on
the house floor
she recently set off the metal detectors
at the house of representatives it this
is a this is a wacky wacky person
she tweeted something which exposed her
complete lack of knowledge about the
minimum wage and economics
she said quote i got my start working at
mcdonald's
that job doesn't exist if the minimum
wage is raised to 15 dollars per hour
small business would be crushed by this
arbitrary mandate
and big business would simply automate
away jobs
not everything that sounds good is
actually good in practice
it is stunning how many bad arguments
she was able to squeeze into that one
tweet first of all she claims jobs at
mcdonald's don't exist
if you raise the minimum wage to fifteen
dollars per hour minimum wage in
washington dc
is fifteen dollars per hour mcdonald's
exist
debunked number two she says that it's
arbitrary
to make the minimum wage 15 an hour this
is an argument we often hear from people
who come in and say
listen if you're just picking a number
and more money for people is good
why stop at 15 an hour make the minimum
wage 100
an hour make it a thousand dollars an
hour and of course
they are wrong that it is arbitrary a a
hundred or a thousand
uh dollar an hour minimum wage is not
defensible
on the basis of cost of living on the
basis of work
and productivity generated by employees
in
typical minimum wage jobs it's not an
equilibrium wage
in the market so they want to say oh
it's our
15 bucks it could be 12 it could be a
hundred make it a thousand why not no no
no
there's nothing arbitrary about it and
15 is probably
a hair too low in some places due to
cost of living
and in in some other places you could
argue
there are really low cost of living
places where maybe you could argue 15 is
too high relative to cost of living and
and revenue at small businesses but
the idea that it's arbitrary is just
completely wrong
and uh what what you have to understand
what is she missing here and she's
missing a lot
remember that labor is only one
input at a place like mcdonald's and
we've studied
how meaningful wage increases at places
like mcdonald's
would have a very small impact on the
total cost
not the price the cost of a big mac
and clueless people have scammed their
way
into positions of power by attaching
themselves to the trump scam train and
republican voters fell for it
and now you have people like lauren
bobert who don't know anything
in positions of power you also have to
remember
that when you increase the minimum wage
you're creating demand side stimulus
even though it might cost mcdonald's a
little more to make the big mac
because of the increased minimum wage
way more people
now have money to go buy more big macs
that's the demand side
stimulus component she also mentions
they would automate jobs
mcdonald's has already been doing that
for a very long time both in areas where
there is a fifteen dollar minimum wage a
fourteen dollar minimum wage a thirteen
dollar minimum wage
and a seven dollar minimum wage they've
already been automating these touch
screen
ordering machines app-based delivery and
collection or you know all this
different stuff
um and so it of course it's a total
misunderstanding by lauren bobert
i don't think anyone's shocked that she
doesn't know a damn thing about
economics
but the reality is that we're only going
to get more of this if at some point
the republican party doesn't say we have
to
this has to stop even people like you
know okay
i would disagree with mitt romney on
policy
but he has a better understanding of at
least
what the terms of the debate are and how
it should be discussed
we would come to different conclusions
he would have some bad ideas i'm sure
about supply-side
economics as an example but this is just
a cartoonish farce people like lauren
beaubert and if the republican party
learned
anything from the trump fiasco it would
be to make sure that in the 2022
election
all of these nuts lose that and i don't
know that republicans have actually
learned that
let me know if you think they have we'll
be back right after this
when you see me sitting here at the
microphone oftentimes i'm wearing
a shirt by a company called teddy
stratford and i love these shirts so
much
that i asked teddy stratford to be a
sponsor of the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird-looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper that's
hidden
underneath the buttons which secures the
shirt against your chest so it doesn't
look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really improve the way your
upper body looks when you're wearing it
it also has a special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down and
spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things
really do a lot to make a big difference
when you're looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout